[Music]
all right spent more than two weeks the
Department of Justice Inspector General
Michael Horowitz completed his report
detailing how James Comey other top FBI
officials handled the criminal case
against then presidential candidate
Hillary Clinton of course this came
after 18 long months of diligent work
500 people from the Inspector General's
team but now these extremely important
findings are still being delayed
installed we're in the Department of
Justice the same people that have been
obstructing Congress by the very same
people responsible for redacting
withholding and ignoring subpoenaed
documents from members of Congress who
are trying to do their constitutional
duty of oversight as required by the
Constitution every American tonight
needs to be demanding that this report
is released in full right now but don't
bury at this Thursday or Friday leading
into the Trump summit now earlier the
president tweeted this quote what is
taking so long with the inspector
general's report on crooked Hillary and
slippery James Comey numerous delays who
hope the report is not being changed and
made weaker there are so many horrible
things to tell the public has a right to
know transparency now journalist Sarah
Carter is shining huge light on this
story tonight on why the IG report has
yet to be released and she is revealing
that the IG is being pressured to delay
their findings slow walk their findings
and also get this they probably want to
release it on the weekend heading into a
big summit with President Trump and Kim
jong-un she writes that quote the
Department of Justice the FBI are
deliberately attempting a slow roll and
redact significant portions of the
Inspector General's report and that's
not all
some are now concerned the DOJ is
planning to bury this report on a summer
Friday like this Friday leading into
next week summit now perhaps ahead of
that meeting with Kim jong-un in
Singapore next Tuesday you the public
have a right to see this information
this has taken 18 months they cannot
bury this they cannot alter this they
cannot redact this and it apparently
seems to be slow walk and they're trying
everything they can do to take out
the important findings here our
questions deserve to be answered where's
the report on the now-infamous
tarmac meeting between Bill Clinton and
Loretta Lynch they were talking about
their grandkids really where's the
report on James Comey issuing what
writing exoneration after exoneration on
Hillary Clinton in May before he even
interviewed Hillary and 17 other key
witnesses where's the report on why the
FBI looked the other way as Hillary
Clinton literally destroyed evidence as
she deleted 33,000 subpoenaed emails
acid washed her hard drive with bleach
fit and had an aide break up her devices
with a hammer now tonight we did reach
out to the DOJ shockingly they disliked
declined to comment and while we await
the IGS report detailing how the fix was
in fact in for Hillary Clinton how
Hillary Clinton did commit felonies we
do have new information surrounding
former Navy sailor Christian saucier
remember him he wasn't given any special
insider Clinton treatment Hillary
Clinton willfully mishandled top-secret
special access information on a private
email that lied about at all
she's been oh she didn't have any
charges brought against her poor
Christian saucier he took six pictures
inside of a submarine that he was proud
to work on never put him out in the
public he was put in federal prison for
a year before being pardoned by
President Trump now Christian saucier
rightly is suing President Obama James
Comey claiming that he was subject to
unequal protection under the law good
for him
unequal protection under the law our
two-tier justice system pretty much
sounds about right sadly now speaking of
which the former deputy director of the
FBI Andrew McCabe he was fired as we
know for lying still has not been
charged with any crime there is a
criminal referral now McCabe is now
reportedly asking the US Senate for
immunity in exchange for his testimony
in their ongoing investigation into the
FBI's mishandling of the Clinton
investigation I said it in January it's
the year of the boomerang and this is
now becoming a circular firing squad
among some of the top levels of the deep
State you will have more on this tonight
in just a moment now first we have some
not so shocking news about so-called
journalism in America look at this new
poll from
the Pew Research Center 70 percent of
the American people now have news
fatigue well maybe just maybe good guess
on my part
maybe the American people are tired of
the media's obsessive compulsive
non-stop hysteria and breathless support
of reporting surrounding the mainstream
media's news coverage they're false
panic over North Korea and nuclear war
they're false panic over the Trump tax
cuts their false panic over so-called
collusion with no evidence and now false
panic over a so-called
constitutional crisis watch what our
friends at the media Research Center and
I was put together tonight
president Trump declares he has the
power to pardon himself unleashing new
fears about his response to the Russian
investigation and the possibility of a
constitutional crisis we're heading into
a constitutional crisis so are we at a
crisis point here maybe where are the
constitutional crisis I don't know we
hear the phrase constitutional crisis
repeated over and over again on the
verge of a constitutional crisis it's a
view of the presidency imbued with
absolute power that raises the specter
of a constitutional question or crisis
even this is exactly the kind of
constitutional crisis experts have been
warning about when does it cross over
into being a constitutional crisis I
told you they're lazy they're overpaid
they don't do their work and they just
echo each other and they try to outrage
each other maybe the American people
clearly they're tired of the Metis
combative blatant abusively biased anti
Trump stance that they take every day
like this example from today's press
briefing featuring the Trump truncating
pretend journalists in this case April
Ryan well Jim Acosta got a break in
terms of our show watch press secretary
Sarah Sanders respond take a look if the
president's aware that this is an RHC
involved shooting and not about
disrespecting the flag is the president
they even put on pads is the president
aware the taking the knee is about
police involved shootings the president
has made his position crystal clear and
that it's about I let you rudely
interrupt me and your colleague I'm
gonna ask that you allow me to finish my
answer I would be happy to answer it if
you would stop talking long enough to
let me do that the president has made
his position crystal clear on this topic
he feels strongly that standing for our
national anthem is something that we
should do this has been made a political
argument of which the president is not
going to back down from and he's been
clear on it steamin last question we
deal with paper I have addressed your
Russian and I'm not going to continue to
engage with you Steven that was now
telling people they have to stand
will the president deal with the issue
of police involved shooting I'm gonna
deal with the issue of addressing your
colleagues question and worst of all
maybe you the American people may be
just tired of the media's downright
nasty personal attacks including the
recent coverage of the first lady our
first lady Melania Trump now of course
following a medical procedure for a
kidney condition three weeks ago well
the first lady well she was only seen
once in the public spotlight by the way
leaving some in the press running
absolutely wild with insane speculation
pushing some of the nastiest vicious
conspiracy theories you'll ever see
look at this writer for Rolling Stones
tweeting well I wish that I didn't
suspect that the prolong poorly
explained public absence of Melania
Trump could be about concealing abuse I
wish that it was a ludicrous prospect
I wish the president wasn't a man of a
history of abusing women including those
to whom he is married that's outrageous
disgusting and so predictable from your
media and that's not all look at good
old David from a never Trump or tweeting
quote supposed president Trump punched
the first lady in the White House
federal property equals federal
jurisdiction then ordered the Secret
Service to conceal the assault
the president has Article two authority
over the Secret Service is that
obstruction under seculow doubt
apparently no of course this disgusting
speculation continued even on television
this is how insane your media has become
this is a mass psychosis that kicked in
about 10:00 p.m.
November
20:16 when the person they thought would
never win won by a big margin take a
look a lot of people are wondering where
the first lady is these days she dropped
out of sight several weeks ago I they're
saying we haven't seen her since the
10th and everyone has their questions
about where is she the last time we
caught a glimpse of her was on Marta May
10th 24 days more than three weeks
there's been a lot of questions about
her surgery her time at Walter Reed and
now her invisibility how long does she
have to be out of sight to make this a
legitimate media story first ladies get
media coverage I don't care what your
political ideology is when a first lady
disappears from the public saying 24
days after being in a hospital of course
reporters are going to raise questions
as of the time we're taping the show
right now the first lady has not been
seen in public for 25 days well I'm not
surprised it took that shawshank guy
years to tunnel out this is so
despicable even beneath the dignity of
them so-called comedian so-called
journalists well there are actually four
of them last week that saw Melania Trump
but said nothing I have multiple sources
confirming that tonight and by the way
she did have an operation maybe wishing
her well would be the appropriate
response the first lady did respond on
Twitter writing I see the media's
working overtime speculating where I am
what I'm doing rest assured I'm here at
the White House with my family feeling
great and working hard on behalf of
children and the American people would
that shut them up probably not that's
how sick they are and another anti Trump
non-story the mainstream media pushing
literally this time surrounding the
Philadelphia Eagles being disinvited to
the White House following the big Super
Bowl victory earlier today the press
secretary Sarah Sanders responded good
for her take a look at this there were
80 members of the Eagles organization
that RSVP'd and committed to attend this
event as recently as Friday as well as
over a thousand fans of the Eagles
organization
and the Eagles are the ones that tried
to change their commitment at the 11th
hour and the president frankly thinks
that the fans deserve better than that
this wasn't a political stunt by the
Eagles franchise then they wouldn't have
planned to attend the event and then
backed out at the last minute and if it
wasn't a political stunt and they
wouldn't have attempted to reschedule
the visit when they knew that the
president was going to be overseas and
if this wasn't a political stunt they
wouldn't have waited until Monday well
after a thousand of their fans had
travelled and taken time out of their
schedules to offer only a tiny handful
of representatives to attend the event
yeah great treatment of the Eagles fans
in this particular case the president
was right to cancel this event and by
the way look at the NFL today look at
this rule the new rule requiring players
you know that's to actually stand for
the anthem or else they can go hide in
the locker room look at the owner of the
New York Jets offering to pay the fines
of any player on his team who protests
the ants the anthem you know what I've
had it this is ridiculous I'm supposed
to tune into a football game and watch a
bunch of people that make a lot of money
making a statement not the Eagles in
this particular case but they made a
political statement as relates to the
White House
really now it's they're gonna hide in a
locker room while the flag is waving and
we're honoring men and women that fought
bled and died for their country fighting
for under that flag look at what Roger
Goodell and other NFL owners have done
to this league it's disgusting
let me be clear I'm done with my Jets in
fact I'm done with the NFL my football
day is Saturday I like college football
and until and unless members of the
National Football League gained the
respect for the flag in this country and
those that have sacrificed bled and died
fighting under that flag I'm finished
instead of celebrating a football team
today the president rightly hosted a
celebration for America
featuring yeah the Marine Corps band and
the army course and today Americans do
have so much to celebrate
including a booming economy Wow so
different than just 501 days ago take a
look a country has never done better
than it's doing right now
never record numbers at every outpost
you take a look at what's going on
lowest unemployment numbers we've had
lowest african-american unemployment in
the history of our country lowest
hispanic numbers in the history of our
country lowest numbers for women in 21
years we've created seven trillion
dollars of value in our country since
the election
with the largest economy in the world
and getting a lot larger and fast it's
happened very quickly actually quicker
than I even thought only 501 days by the
way what the president is announcing
good news for America bad news for the
Democratic Party in your corrupt media
why because they want the president to
fail obviously they want to destroy
Trump at any cost him being successful
is not good towards that goal and their
little egos can remain intact and by the
way their friends in the Democratic
Party they're so hoping can regain power
that's why this midterm election will be
the most important in our lifetime but
that's not gonna stop the president's
economic policies from vastly improving
this country remember the Forgotten men
and women we've reported about the
historically low unemployment rates and
now the Atlanta Fed is making a
prediction the economy is going to grow
second quarter at a rate of 4.8%
all right let's compare this to the
eight years of Obama remember they told
us that Oh 1% growth was the new normal
for the United States we just all accept
it in other words a crappy economy you
might remember 13 million more Americans
on food stamps under Obama eight years
eight million more in poverty the lowest
labor participation rate since the 70s
the worst recovery since the 40s the
lowest homeownership rate in 51 years
and the doubling of our national debt
which President Obama then said was
irresponsible and unpatriotic thank god
the era of failure in obama is over and
his destructive regulations his high
taxes have come to an end and America's
economy
is now after a 501 days of Trump booming
look at your screen candidate Trump
promised big wins for the United States
high economic growth lower taxes fewer
regulations and jobs jobs jobs by the
way you tired of winning tonight